summer linen suit casual but classic
actually not bad one question can you
see my underwear ah thong why are you
wearing a thong it's why something
borrowed why did you stop me I was
making progress I know sir but I have to
say something I love the 99 and the main
reason why is you not Jake yes clearly
it's mostly Jake but it's also you and
the standard that you set for us with
your unwavering morals
I'd rather we split up than stay
together and compromise Who We Are
well thank you Boyle you're right no
matter what happens we'll feel better
knowing we didn't resort to Blackmail I
agree from now on the only blackmail I
want anything to do with is you
that was incredibly inappropriate I know
but I had thought of it and I was so
proud I just had to say it out loud
let's just go great
hey there Sarge not deprived but I
couldn't help it over here you're going
to the doctor everything okay
I'm getting a vasectomy my ears are
burning someone say vasectomy I got
snipped no big deal just numbs you out
from trunk to skunk for a year it's not
supposed to trunk to skunk hold it up
you're gonna let some quack doctor just
knife around down there you are blessed
with a great power
and you should never snip its wings you
should let it soar thanks guys that's
enough I don't need any more input
neither does your wife I guess
you talking all this bags
68. that's not that old yeah but I was
only 20 20. were you even a cop then no
man it was before I got into the academy
Charles isn't talking about his oldest
arrest
no yes yes I am yeah all this arrest 68
like I said God you had sex with a 68
year old when you were in your 20s you
know how it is when you have a chance to
bet an older woman no that is not an
older woman that's an old woman that's
someone's grandma she was actually
that's how I met her
until now I can see a trick she had a
replacement hit with some serious torque
no like having sex with a Transformer
that is no one's fantasy as always there
will be no spouses no bosses no work no
bedtimes within reason all right
Santiago's feeling Rowdy who else is
feeling it I can't wait this weekend I
am vacation Terry no kids no
responsibilities I'm just a balloon
floating in the great blue sky and I am
untouched and just to clarify how
untethered is vacation Terry from his
wife very tethered all right something
I'd like to say a pretty private person
so this is kind of hard for me but
here we go
I'm bisexual all right I will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go Amy how long have
you known since seventh grade I was
watching Saved by the Bell and I thought
Zack Morris is hot and then I thought at
least a turtle also hot the fact that
the words Kelly and capacity didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now Charles
found out on the road trip and I was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep a secret for much longer bye Rosa
I mean not bye but bye I mean see ya I
mean have fun only having sex with men
just being a dudes left and right I just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we want to look her up yes I am next do
you know Anne Heche I do I must say this
is going considerably better than when I
came out to my colleagues they were not
as the kids say awake do you mean woke I
didn't mean woke but it's grammatically
incoherent okay we have time for one
more question no no absolutely not we're
done
smart he was not tasteful my ex-wife's
throwing an engagement party this
weekend and I was wondering if you
wanted to go as friends no Charles just
because we have Secret
shameful sex does not mean we are
friends Cricket friends let's go as bone
Bros
I didn't strike you when you said
knocking boots but bone Bros
cannot abide
is uh everything okay Santiago no I lost
my ring did you see where it went
actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one are you trying to
Monkey haul me it's unbelievable I don't
need Monty Hall ruining my place of work
but Monty Hall has already ruined my
home life come on Sir the math thing
isn't the problem night shift's keeping
you and Kevin apart you two just need a
bone
what did you say
I said you two need a bone
oh there you
are detective Diaz I am your Superior
officer phone what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business
boom don't ever speak to me like that
again
[Music]
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
it's in I know you don't want to talk
about Monty Hall but I did contact a
math professor no need Santiago it's all
good so the fight with Kevin is over yep
because you understand the map nope
because you guys yep for you
and you and you what are these these
madam are STDs
what are you talking about Buddy STDs
save the dates for Viviana my wedding ah
yes hey just out of curiosity how many
people have you given STDs to Lots like
a hundred
what's going on uh oh okay I get it STD
has another meaning you're gross no one
else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet will your first dance
be to you give me fever will you be
serving crabs at the reception do you
have herpes guys this is my wedding this
is important to me no more jokes you're
right and we're sorry yes we love you
buddy warts and all it's all right I
made a rash decision I was itching to
say it okay I'm done
I have an STD
so just RSVP or yeah the numbers right
on the answers great why would you keep
this from me and why would you lie about
going to fencing because he couldn't go
because he's injured I wasn't injured I
was lightly stabbed I'm sorry you were
stabbed lightly stabbed I didn't want to
frighten you
you are my husband I want you to tell me
everything especially things that might
frighten me how can you not know that
Raymond you are unbelievable
foreign
hey Captain you look so tall what you
have done is beyond unprofessional you
cannot muck around in people's private
lives get out of my house uh get into
your car I'll go
so my stance feels good but I'm still
not hitting Center all right back your
left foot up a hair like this
no
no it's over this you won't show me like
wrap your thick muscular arms around me
and all right look hands here stand up
straight chin forward hold on I know
they're just Gina I got the squad to
volunteer a little bit of their off time
to help you and your family house
I'll make dinner once a week everybody
else volunteered babysitting time and
Hitchcock offered massage sessions for
your wife what soy pepper sprayed him
you're a good man child
how can I ever thank you start taking
care of yourself again
I miss those gross overly large muscles
lay off my body dude I clearly got some
stuff to work through